let me frame we're not hmm I am alright
let's go I'm swimming around and every
China I'm swimming around and over kinda
swimming around and over Jelena I try to
make I looked it alright so I got a
really rude comment saying oh you have
to you have to put the key here it's so
obvious
Jesus Christ are you [ __ ] [ __ ]
well guess what I'm not [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's not even a right place so [ __ ]
yeah it was even like I don't know
seriously it's obvious how the [ __ ]
should I put the lock here and you
telling me I'm stupid
hmm you know Tammy I'm tripping maybe it
is their house I don't know if there's
[ __ ] stones down I'm swimming around
it of Jelena I'm swimming around in a
vagina I'm swimming around the no vagina
I just have everyone who watch you think
they're so [ __ ] smart and be like oh
it's here and then there's so [ __ ]
wrong I don't know
but it's alright cuz I got peek at you
yeah yeah s'up [ __ ] oh oh hey look at
this beauty you know there's a mattress
here you know there's a lot of things
you can do on these you know a lot of
babies can be born I mean made ah undies
you know you like that you like when I
slide my oh look and I'm doing this step
for you oh yeah yeah yeah oh you like
what are you doing you like when I put
my balls in my ear face be
you like that you like when I put my
balls in your face yeah oh all right
let's do that another night I think I
have to go back and use the key
somewhere else I'm not sure because
there it is there's one door I need to
keep get out of here you stupid [ __ ]
maybe I should sheet probably better
idea sheet or not I don't know let's go
back to the kitchen I spout
it's so obvious reading no it's not it's
not obvious I know I don't trust any one
of you I detest you not just you and I
Jesse you alright let's see we're
barrels let's not go there
alright here's where the key goes thank
you both so much for telling me
[ __ ] it when your anyway this is the
last door I think so let's see what's in
the am scared and I'm six oh that's not
a good combination what the hell is you
doing there is he crying the hell I
never seen that animation before
alright let's not look at him maybe
you've just jacked off in felt guilty oh
no no I was just the key is in one our
prison second but well you will see dr.
Jones dr. Jones dr. Jones empty what are
you doing is he talking to someone
what's he doing
I'll never know it's talking he's
talking to just so fun I know I didn't
know all right someone with their pants
here so let's go through the garden back
of the Nama out of ideas maybe here ooh
you see that jump on there all right
yeah how do I go holy dude of Keilar
cough cough a lot a big one over there
all right this way hey ah that's nothing
perfect I just love when they put
nothing there okay nice castle Brock
stop bracing your love all right
I'm stop wasting time shop way hey a
closet and a life partner oh man I got
someone to debug this 16 really that's
awesome
the guy who made is not as pretty
[ __ ] good at hiding keys I'm guessing
ail I love oil Bible
no thank you I am oh look at this one I
like that I like that a lot
all right let's just lift up because
it's cozy and [ __ ]
can we go here nothing perfect
I just felt when there's enough it feels
good ah maybe their secrets behind this
it's just ketchup it's more ketchup
ketchup everywhere
what the hell
what that freak Leaf Rag fruit oh look
the who's gonna I was gonna take that
little key there you got there buddy
let me take a king ah I'm breakdown
saying no it's not to have a breakout
egg I didn't even know what to do sunday
pigeons
let's drink all of them harm drug no
problem alright okay let's just go ahead
thought about it make you guys other
like let me take my sanity potion let's
get drunk on Santa poison yeah yeah I'm
drunk okay yeah yeah are you doing I am
doing are you ripping the guy can't even
draw that let me take that yeah man okay
you're [ __ ] hi
Jason's guys what are we doing here
something all right fantastic the dagger
can kill him come here buddy
[Applause]
why can't I take it I think it's stuck I
think it's supposed to break but it
doesn't oh no oh no oh no Otto Otto Otto
back ah all right
Tynan boxes all right that didn't
exactly go as planned but we learned a
few things
there's tender boxes on top of that
Chili's is nothing mr. chair you better
have a good [ __ ] explanation while
you were talking
I'm sorry you smell I can keep that I
can tell you that his mouth and I don't
like his attitude and I think you're
much better and I would rather today
with you pity that's good good answer
we got something here what is he there I
don't know pity it's it's like the
questions of life why is the universe
upside down and why am i a share and
still talking it's like a lot of
question you can keep asking but I think
you have to go this way and then get out
get the key I'm velvet I'm expensive be
careful please all right all right do
you remember the key of course I
remember the key walls D sky it's right
here by the ketchup I don't want to put
put don't put me down in ketchup thank
you hi morning what is whatever all
right your rescue sweet see you later
[ __ ]
all right yeah yeah all right let's go
to garden PD I can't come with you
though I'm just gonna share them on
active poop I'll see you later
I see you bought bond by ash mr. sheriff
did we go here I don't remember that
another exit of staff not an accident
that's not an exit obviously yeah yeah I
got my health good yeah yeah I can't
talk I'm all right
what is this it's a real long costume
sorry I didn't explain either be that
long
all right let's finish this well except
for all by the pee stain I love these
things
if I could lick this I will all right
let's go okay hey I made it I made it
look last note you're the first person
who made it you can go but please take
the present so close
oh man just the friggin test what nah oh
that was freaking crazy
ah Wow 15 minutes oh yeah I got lost and
stuff like that so funny I got a few
anyway hope you bros enjoyed that was a
great cousin story thumbs up so every
day it could have been better but never
a myth anyway hope you enjoyed I like it
food if you did subscribe to come on bro
today and I'll see you next episode
[Music]